pour en parler nous sommes avec pierre
garnodier secrétaire général de la cgt
pour les précaires et les chômeurs
bonsoir monsieur garneau d'être avec
nous sur rt france vous avez écouté le
premier ministre qui s'est exprimé sur
france 2 ce soir qu'en avez-vous pensé
oui tout à fait le premier ministre a
réaffirmé sa détermination et appelle
les organisations syndicales à prendre
leurs responsabilités
nous réaffirmons ici notre détermination
pour le retrait de ce projet de loi et
nous prenons tout notre responsabilité
puisque nous notre responsabilité à va
envers les travailleurs de ce pays du
public du privé ceux qui sont privés
d'emploi et précaires et nous leur
disons ici ce projet de loi cette
réforme de retraites à points
c'est un projet qui est néfaste et qui
serait catastrophique pour l'ensemble
des travailleurs de spip donc la
mobilisation est maintenue jeudi il y
aura une grande manifestation encore
dans les rues de france
oui bien sur la cgt appelle à la grève
les 14 15 et 16 janvier prochain est
d'ores et déjà il ya une manifestation
qui est prévue jeudi à l'appel de
l'intersyndicale cgt et fo cfe cgc et
sud et des organisations de jeunesse
qu'est ce que pour les précaires qu'est
ce que ça implique c'est vrai qu'on n'en
parle pas beaucoup et les précaires et
les gens qui ont connu des des longues
périodes de chômage est ce que qu'est ce
que cette réforme va va changer ou pas
alors le ça va changer puisque l'on va
changer totalement d'architecturé de
retraites et la réforme par points elle
va fortement impacter le déni n'est pas
nous les futures pensions des des
chômeurs dans le système actuel on
cotise les chômeurs et cotise selon leur
salaire qu'ils ont perdu pour leur
retraite
avec la réforme des retraites par points
les chômeurs les privés d'emploi ils
vont se voir attribuer des points non
plus en fonction de leur ancien salaire
du salaire qui a été perdu mais en
fonction de leurs indemnités chômage est
seulement de la r donc allocation de
retour à l'emploi
ce qui fait qu automatiquement les
futures pensions seront beaucoup plus
basses et que cette serre trade qui sera
construit avec des points attribués sur
la base de l'indemnité chômage elle ne
se fera
qu'en fonction de mécanismes de
solidarité nationale qui sera décidée
unilatéralement par gouvernement donc
c'est le gouvernement qui décidera tout
seul des points qu'on pourra s'attribuer
en fonctionnant autres indemnités
donc en gros les retraites des
travailleurs privés d'emploi deviendra
une simple variable d'ajustement du
budget de l'état et c'est bien
évidemment nous nous le refusons et nous
disons que les travailleurs qui sont
privés d'emploi ils doivent continuer à
cotiser
selon le salaire qu'ils ont perdu
d'autant que les indemnisations vont
baisser on l'a vu avec la réforme
justement sur l'assurance chômage donc
mécaniquement a effectivement les
pensions ont baissé quoi exactement est
ça c'est le deuxième gros gros points
contre lequel on se bat effectivement
dans cette réforme là puisque la réforme
des retraites elle intervient quelques
mois après l'application la première
mise en application du décret du 26
juillet effectivement qui nécessite de
travailler six mois pour ouvrir des
droits au lieu de quatre actuellement et
qu'automatiquement 750 mille chômeurs
vont être exclues de tout droit à
l'indemnisation et que déjà 20%
seulement des chômeurs soient indemnisés
et donc pour tous ces chômeurs là qui ne
sont pas indemnisés et bien
effectivement il ya une question de dire
quelle retraite on va avoir le
gouvernement il a annoncé la retraite
plancher de 1000 euros mais cette
retraite là il faut bien comprendre que
elle ne sera que pour les travailleurs
qui ont cotisé pendant quarante-trois
années complètes de temps de travail
sinon ça va être un pourcentage de ses
1000 euros donc si vous n'avez travail
et que 80% des quarante trois années
eh ben vous aurez 800 euros donc c'est
des retraites qui seront inférieures au
minimum vieillesse qui aujourd'hui de
868 euros
il faut dire que déjà actuellement dans
ce pays il ya cinq cent mille retraités
qui sont minimum vieillesse 550 mille
pardons retraités qui sont minimum
vieillesse et que par conséquent 500
mille d'entre eux se voient contraints
de cumuler un emploi et une retraite et
c'est ça la réforme du gouvernement
c'est à ce niveau que le retrait de cet
âge pivot annoncé hier par le premier
ministre c'était vraiment la mesure
contestée 1 par une majorité de français
le calendrier
est assez serré puisque le texte a déjà
été présenté au conseil d'état vous
croyez vraiment pouvoir parvenir à faire
retirer complètement cette réforme non
mais même bertrand martinot qui est un
ancien conseiller social à lisez donc ce
n'est pas la cgt qu'il le dise est
blessé lui il le dit lui-même que en fin
de compte la question de l'âge de la chp
niveau c1 c'est un recul tactique c'est
pour les médias voilà c'est pour
l'opinion publique service que et
c'était le l'objet des négociations
qu'on pouvait lâcher le gouvernement
pour l'acheter vous en faite il ya deux
âges pivots il ya l'âge pivot pour les
années 2000 22 à 2027
donc c'est l'âge pivot de court terme l
âge pivot de long terme c'est pour ça
l'âge pivot pour tous ceux qui sont nés
après 75
on ne pourra pas toucher à l'âge pivot
de long terme c'est à dire que pour tous
ceux qui sont nés pardon après 115 lâche
niveau il restera il y aura toujours un
hash pivot et pour ce qui concerne l'âge
pivot à court terme donc pour 2022 à
2027 le gouvernement il nous donne d une
lettre de cadrage un peu comme pour
l'assurance chômage
en dix ans il faut déséquilibre il faut
un équilibre financier et vous allez me
trouver des solutions mais sans toucher
aux ressources ça veut dire que nous la
cgt on a des solutions
on dit notamment qu'il faut que les
cotisations patronales il faut qu'elles
augmentent bon et 20,5 gouvernement il
veut pas le smic augmente
voilà par exemple parce que ce qu'il
faut bien se dire c'est que nous à la
cgt l'equilibre qu'on veut c'est celui
entre le capital et le travail sur les
trente dernières années il ya 200
milliards d'euros qui sont parce qu'ils
sont passés par bing de la poche des
salariés à celle des actionnaires 57
milliards d'euros de dividendes cette
année donc il ya un équilibre
effectivement à trouver mais l'
équilibre c'est celui d'un rééquilibrage
du capital d'art le travail pour le
financement de nos retraites pour le
financement notre sécurité sociale et
donc cette condition de
de vous renvoyer la balle pour trouver
cette solution vous y croyez vous allez
pouvoir vous entendre entre syndicats
non pas du tout parce qu'en réalité
c'est ce qui s'est passé pour
l'assurance chômage vous savez pour
l'assurance chômage le gouvernement il
nous a dit vous allez faire des
négociations mais ces négociations il y
aura une lettre de cadrage autour et on
va vous dire il faut que vous négociez
une baisse de 3 24 milliards d'euros de
baisses de droits des animaux de
l'indemnisation des chômeurs les
négociations et échoué elle le
gouvernement est venu avec ce décret qui
est une véritable saignée du droit à
l'indemnisation chômage
et bien pour les retraites c'est la même
chose le gouvernement il veut que les
organisations syndicales
elle négocie la misère nous la cgt ont
négocié négocie pas la misère nous à la
cgt ce qu'ont négociés c'est le progrès
social
donc c'est bien pour ça qu'on appelle de
nouveau à des journées de mobilisation
parce qu'il faut que les travailleurs en
ait conscience où on a une capacité
d'action sur ce gouvernement et notre
capacité d'action
la seule arme dont on dispose c'est la
grève donc il faut que tous les
travailleurs du public du privé
précaires et privés d'emploi rentrer
dans l'action participent aux
manifestations rentrer dans la grève
pour infléchir le gouvernement et
imposer la réponse à l'urgence sociale
puisqu'il ya une urgence sociale dans ce
pays encore une fois les retraites
elles sont trop basses 31% des retraites
sont inférieurs à 1000 euros
donc aujourd'hui le gouvernement il doit
répondre à cette urgence sociale là il
ya un problème humain et le problème
humain pour nous il est bien avant deux
problèmes financiers et même d'ailleurs
problèmes financiers il est quand même
un peu floue puisque je rappelle qu'en
2018 les exonérations de cotisations
sociales nous ont coûté 52 milliards
d'euros pour la seule caisse des
retraites l'état il est qu'on pense que
très partiellement est le déficit de la
caisse de retraite pour cette même année
était de 3,5 milliards d'euros il
faudrait quand même que le gouvernement
il éclaire 6 un peu ce sujet là et qu'on
sache vraiment si les caisses elles sont
si vite qu'on le prétend merci beaucoup
pierre garden y est d'avoir répondu à
nos questions sur rt france voilà merci
est donc surtout on appelle à la
mobilisation 14 15 et 16 janvier
prochains en acompte